اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء من العربيه وهذه نشره خاصه تحمل
عنوانا واحده
المغرب يسجل انجازا تاريخيا بالفوز على
اسبانيا ويصعد لاول مره لدور الثمانيه
بالمونديال
[تصفيق]
المغرب في الحكومه
[موسيقى]
عربيه كبيره تعوم الان العواصم العربيه
اتحقق المنتخب
بعد فوزه تاريخيه على المنتخب الاسباني
بركلات الترجيح عقد تعادل سلبي الذي خيم
على شوطين الاساسيين والاضافيين وبذلك
يكون المغرب اول منتخب عربي يتاهل لدور
ثمانيه وسيلتقي المنتخب المغربي بالفائز
من مباراه البرتغال وسويسرا التي ستقام
بعد قليل نحن امام انجاز تاريخيا بكل
المقاييس ليس فقط للمغرب ولكن لكل العرب
بعد ان نجح المغرب في تمثيل الفرق العربيه
لاول مره في تاريخ بطوله كاس العالم يصعد
فريق عربي الى دور الثمانيه في انجاز يصعد
الجماهير العربيه في كل مكان خاصه بعد
خروج قطر وتونس والسعوديه ها هو المغرب
يحقق حلم العرب في هذا الصعود المغرب له
تاريخ طويل في التاهل لبطوله كاس العالم
تاريخيا دخل كاس العالم عام 1970 اول مره
دخل كاس العالم عام
1986 و
1994 و
و2018 وبالمناسبه في 2018 التقى المنتخب
الاسباني وكانت النتيجه التعادل هدفين
مقابل هدفين ولكن هذه المره نحن امام
انجاز تاريخيا مختلف بكل المقاييس كان
دائما يتم تصنيف ان اقوى المشاركات
المغربيه كانت عام 86 ولكن التاريخ سيعدل
نفسه سريعا اليوم ليسجل هذا الانجاز
للمغرب كافضل اداء للمنتخب المغربي في
تاريخ بطوله كاس العالم تنضم الى الاجواء
في الدوحه وانضم الينا زميلي ليث همم
بازاري اهلا بك ليث معنا على شاشه العربيه
فرحه عامه الان في الدوحه انقل لناصر
من هنا من امام ملعب المدينه التعليميه
ايديوكيشن سيتي ترشح او تدخل المغرب في
الدور الربع النهائي لكاس العالم هنا في
قطر حتى هذه اللحظه شاهدنا بعد المشجعين
الذين خرجوا من هذا ستاد من هذا الملعب
ملعب المدينه التعليميه ولكن في الطريق
للوصول الى خارج الملعب يعني نحن على
الوقت تماما همم انت مغربي صح شو رايك
بالنتيجه شو رايك
للمغرب يعني فرصه جيده لانه من زمان ما
همم فازوا في كاس العالم
المنتخب المغربي وشرف شرف العرب وشرف
الكره الافريقيه وشمال افريقيا كلها احنا
كان نقول له البرازيل احنا قادمون ان شاء
الله وسنفوز بالكاس لان الكاس تنظم في
دوله عربيه
وكالعملنا السعوديه وتونس ومسالهم هنا
ولكن حتى ما وفقهمش فتحيه السعوديه وتحيه
لتونس احنا كانقولوا احنا كنكلوكم باحسن
تمثيل والكاس العرب
في الدول العربيه ستبقى في العرب وهذا وعد
المغربي
وعاش الدوله الملكيه وعاش الملكيه انا
وعاش الامراء اليوم
انا توقعاتي كانت اسبانيا بتفوز لانها في
قويه قويه فيها
قوي كمان لكن
اسبانيا قوي شوي وكنت اشجع يعني اشجع
متوتر يعني ممكن لما مجال وقت الزيت 30
دقيقه كنت متوتر كثير لانه صفر صفر
بهذا النصر الذي حقق المنتخب المغربي
احتفل في اني ان اروح همم استعرضوا يعني
اروح ولزقوا واقف يعني اجيبه معي علم
المغرب ان شاء الله سوق واقف على كل حال
رشا انا متاكد سيكون واقفا طول الليل هذه
الليله جميع الذين سيغادرون هذا الملعب
44,652 مشجع ومتفرج هنا سوف ينطلقون الى
هذه المنطقه عادا عن الذين يشجعون من
المناطق اخرى هنا في الدوحه سوف ينطلقون
الى سوق واقف الذي لم يتوقف انا متاكد عن
الاحتفالات طول هذه الليله تفضل الحمد لله
شوف احنا فرحانين اليوم كان عندنا ثقه في
المدرب ديالنا وثيقه في اللاعبين ديالنا
ولماذا ان شاء الله غنمرون ان شاء الله
النصف النهائي
ان شاء الله
اول حاجه شكرا
اشكرهم واحد بواحد لان وقفه مع المنتخب
معنا والدول العربيه الله يجمعنا كيف ما
جمعنا هنا في خطر الله يجمعنا باذن الله
كل ايد واحده مالك مع مالك ورئيس مع رئيس
مشكول وواحد القوه وحنتصروا باذن الله
والوقت الحالي اللي جمعنا قطر وشيخ تميم
حنين سامع ان شاء الله في الدول العربيه
وشكرا لجميع وشكرا للاذاعه العربيه
[تصفيق]
علي علي علي علي
لم تتوقف قبل قبل المباراه ولكن الذي يحدث
هم منفعلون كثيرا مع الذي حدث حدث هنا في
هذا الملعب خلفي الكثير هون
طبعا
لمنتخب المغرب
الى اخر دقيقه وقلنا الحمد لله اللهم اخي
فرحتنا وان شاء الله المباراه الثانيه راح
يكونوا العرب كلهم مبسوطين ان شاء الله شو
اكثر شيء
استاد شو اكثر شيء بين الانواع التشجيع
للمنتخب المغربي والله في
يعني من اول دقيقه واحنا واقفين الى اخر
دقيقه حتى الاخر اخر ضربه كوره اشرف حكيمي
سدد الهدف ما في ولا دقيقه واحده ركزنا
على احد يشجي كنا بنشجع ارجوك
والحمد لله ما راح على الفاضي ودائما
المغرب ان شاء الله
بفوز المنتخب المغربي على اسبانيا وتاهله
لدور قبل الربع نهائي
وسيسجل التاريخ اسم ياسين بونو هذا حارس
المرمى الشهير الذي يدخل التاريخ كره
القدم والمونديال من اوسع ابوابه هذا
الشاب الذي يبلغ من العمر واحدا 31 عاما
ينجح في التصدي
لثلاثه ضربات من قبل اسبانيا دون ان تنجح
اسبانيا في احراز اي هدف في مشهد كان يحمل
فرحه عربيه كبيره من باريس ينضم الينا
الزميل
لنقل فرحه الجماهير المغربيه ايضا من قلب
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
[موسيقى]
هل تسمعني كما تشاهدين الجماهير المغربيه
بدات هنا
انا اسمعك رشا
الجماهير المغربيه
[تصفيق]
قبل او بعد دقائق قليله من انتهاء
المباراه هناك جماهير من مختلف الدول
العربيه وجنسيات هناك ثوانيسا مغاربه
وجزائريين معي احد الاشخاص الذي وصل للتو
من المطار وصل من المغرب ولم يرغب في
الذهاب الى منزله كيف اترى هذا الفوز
اليوم الحمد لله والشكر لله احنا فرحانين
بزاف المباراه
[تصفيق]
بلاش
الجماهير في غايه السعاده والفرحه تعوم
الجميع هنا
[تصفيق]
مبروك
الصوت يتقطع لكن الصوره واضحه تعبر عن
فرحه شديده من الجماهير المغربيه بالطبع
والعربيه في عواصم العالم المختلفه نحن
ننقل صوره من الدوحه عاصمه قطر وننقل صوره
ايضا مع مراسل العربيه من باريس العاصمه
الفرنسيه
وبتاكيد ستكون الاعنا متابعه حيه مع عدد
من العواصم ايضا وسانذهب بالطبع الى قلب
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط لنقل فرحه
المغاربه بهذا الانتصار التاريخي لاول مره
المغرب
تصدر هذه البطوله ويصعد بالفعل الى دوله
ثمانيه كاول منتخب عربي في مسابقه كاس
العالم يصل الى هذه المرحله من التصفيات
فرحه كبيره للغايه من نجد هذا العلم
المغربي وهذه الفرحه المغربيه وهذه الفرحه
العربيه ايضا المغرب اليوم يسعد القلوب
العربيه بعد هذه النتائج الطيبه للغايه
المنتخبات العربيه التي خرج خرجت مبكرا
كقطر وتونس والسعوديه كانت هناك اعمال
تعلق عليهم ولكن اليوم المغرب يعود الجميع
بهذا الانتصار التاريخي وكما ذكرنا
لحضراتكم ياسين بونو هذا حارس المرمى
الرائع وهو ايضا محترف ويلعب في نادي
اشبيليه نجح في التصدي لضربات الجزاء
الثلاثه الاسبانيه ولم تنجح اسبانيا في
تسجيل في اي ركله جزاء على الاطلاق في هذه
همم المباراه المباراه انتهت بعد شوطين
اساسيين وشوطين اضافيين وانتهت بضربات
الجزاء الترجيحيه التي تصدرها وبشكل واضح
ياسين بونو البالغ من العمر واحدا و30
عاما كيف سيكون موقع ياسين بونو في
حراس المرمى في هذه البطوله هذا سؤال
مطروح ايضا منتخب اسبانيا منتخب قوي نجحت
المغرب في ان تخرج نظيفه من الشوطين
الاساسيين والشوطين الاضافيين ايضا دون ان
تنجح اسبانيا في احراز اي هدف بلوا لتخفق
ايضا في تسجيل ضربات الجزاء الترجيحيه
اعود مره اخرى الى الدوحه العاصمه القطريه
وننقل المشاعر العربيه والمشجعات المغاربه
نعم المغربيين المغاربه همم شباب وبنات
هنا يحتفلون كانت الفرحه قبل شويه نطب
السماء من كثر ما هي فرحانه
عمري
مو فاهمين يعني هاي مش مجرد كره قدم
بالنسبه لنا احنا بالمغرب
2018 انا من 2018
واستنى كاس العالم عشان نرش على اللي صار
والحين والحمد لله وان ينصركم الله فلا
غالب عليكم
احنا صرخنا
بيتنا طول الماتش وعملنا اجواء ما بيننا
وكانت الحمد لله حتى صوتي رايح ولكن عادي
الوطن هل كان هناك طبول كان هناك طفول
اكيد من الجهتين الحمد لله احنا كنا
مقطرين على الشبكتين يعني على الشبكه من
هنا والشبكه من هنا كان جنبها قبوله كنا
مؤثرين عليها وكان باغي نقول من هنا راس
لافوكا الرجراجي شكرا بزاف قلت كلمه وكنتي
على حق اللاعب رقم 12 اساسي ومهم وصوتي ها
هو خرج هذا اللاعب رقم 12
ههه
الف مبروك
[ضحك]
مشاعر الاسبان مع صدمه عدم النجاح في
حسم اي من ضربات الجزاء الترجيحيه كانت
ربما حاله الصدمه شديده هي العنوان
الرئيسيه على وجوه الجماهير الاسبانيه لم
يكن يصدق احد ان تفشل اسبانيا في تسديد
ولو لركله واحده
نعم هناك مباراه اخرى ستحسم الامر ايضا مع
من سيلتقي مع المغرب المباراه المرتقبه ما
بين سويسرا والبرتغال هل هناك اي اجواء
تتعلق بهذه المنافسه
بصراحه رشا لا اعرف شيء عن هذه المباراه
نحن هنا من ساعات الظهيره نتابع المنتخب
المغربي حتى حتى نرصد كيف ستكون هذه
المباراه حقيقا ما قالت هذه السيده قبل
قليل هو صحيح الجميع على اعصابه منذ بدايه
المباراه حتى نهايه ضربات الجزاء التي
شاهدنا قبل قليل ولكن يعني الفرحه التي
عمت والصريخ الهتافات والتصفيق من داخل
هذا الاستاذ استاذ المدينه التعليميه
ايديكيشن سيتي هناك لم لا يوصف ما بعرف
اكم ديسيبال بس وكان الصوت مرتفع جدا وهنا
عارفنا مباشره ان المغرب فاز في هذه
المباراه بين اسبانيا والمغرب اتفضل
اتفضل اتفضل انت من المغرب لا انا من
كردستان العراق
من كل المنطقه مش بس من المغرب في كثير
مبروك على كل العرب مبروك على كل الاسلام
احنا افتخرنا بالمغرب الحمد لله وفزناه
وان شاء الله للمره الجايه
من اي مدينه من مدينه المحمديه جانب الدار
البيضاء
اليوم وشجعوا المنتخب المغربي اليوم نعم
هذه الاجواء على كل حال هذا ليس فقط يعني
فوز شكرا لك هذا ليس فقط فوز المنتخب
المغربي عربيا بل افريقيا كذلك فلا يوجد
منتخبات وصلت الى هذا الدور من المنتخبات
الافريقيه ونعرف جميعا ان المغرب المملكه
المغربيه تقع في القاره الافريقيه وهذا
طبعا ادى الى تواجد الكثير من المشجعين
عاد العرب الافارقه الذين قاموا بتسجيع
الماء همم
فرحه شو بدك تقول فرحه لا توصف لانه صراحه
يعني اعتقد ما في منتخب عربي من دون اشعه
البطوله او لحد الان تتاهل لدور الثمانيه
يعني الصراحه بس الحمد لله بشكل عام
المغرب الحمد لله اه ان شاء الله بالضبط
القصر الجزائر
[موسيقى]
انت مغربي صح شكرا نفسي بوكو اتفضل حبيبي
من المغرب من المغرب من وين انت من اي
مدينه من الرباط
محمد الخامس
يعني ايه
يحسوا يعني اللاعبين في المغرب حيث كل
الجمهور كان مع المغرب وكل العرب
شعور المشجعين المغاربه الاسباني
الموجودين في الملعب حسوا ااه شعره وكانه
ولو للحظات انهم يعني المباراه تقام في
المغرب نظرا طبعا
وكل افريقيا معنا السنغال والكاميرون كلهم
معانا شو ممكن تحكي لنا عن ياسين
انا
او سبتك
عندي همم
على كل حال انا سمعت قبل شوي شكرا لك
يعني كبير
عبد الوهاب من المغرب
اه لا والله هي لازم يتحط لهم تمثال في
المغرب بعد والله صاروا بلا خس بونه بونه
هيوحش انا كتبت على صفحتي في الفيسبوك انه
بونو راعي عرين الاسود
اوكياد قوي حق المغرب يحقق نتيجه ايجابيه
فهي شيء نعم
وكمان
كل العالم ورانا بعد ما شاء الله الحمد
لله هذا انجاز قوي فانا قلت بعد سوف نعيد
كره طارق بن زياد ودخول الاندلس فاحنا
دخلنا الى مدريد وان شاء الله بننتظر
البرتغال بعد نعم
ان شاء الله السلام عليكم انت من وين من
ايمن انا من الدار البيضاء نعم ما توصل
انا وصلت
البارح امبارح
للامارات المتحده نعم لهن اليوم يعني وقت
المباراه
كبير
[موسيقى]
والحمد لله بفضل الله وجهودات اللعيبه
والاطار همم
[موسيقى]
اتذكر لمشاهده هذه المباراه فقط ولكنه
سيعود بالطبع لان هناك مباريات قادمه هل
ستعود
نعم نعم هلا راح تغير رايك ترجع على
المغرب وراح تبقى هنا
قررت انني اجي هنا علشان الدور 16 خديت
همم اسبوع
النهائي اوكي كان عندك شعور انه راح يفوز
المغرب صح
ان شاء الله همم اسبوع اخر ان شاء الله
باذن الله
شكرا لكم رشا احنا معكم ممكن نكون حتى
ساعات الصباح ولكن ادعي لي حتى ننقر صوره
صح للمشاهده العربي عبر العربيه
الذين يتركون الملعب ملعب المدينه
التعليميه يذهبون الى السوق واقف الذي قلت
قبل قليل كل الجميع راح يكون واقف في سوق
واقف انا متاكد دعيني اكون معكم بعد قليل
معك الى ان تصل سنتابع الفرحه المغربيه
والعربيه في عواصم العالم المختلفه وهذه
صوت الجماهير المغربيه التي تحتفل في
العاصمه همم الدوحه وايضا سوره
للجماهير المغربيه من قلب العاصمه باريس
وهي ايضا تحتفل بهذا الانتصار التاريخي
تحقق الهدف حتى اللحظه لاول مره منتخب
عربي يصل الى دور ثمانيه في تاريخ بطوله
كاس العالم صعود المنتخب المغربي لم يكن
حظا او لم يكن متوقع غير متوقع كما يعتقد
البعض ولكنه نتيجه اداء مميز منذ هذه
البطوله ومنذ بدايتها تغلب بشكل كبير على
منتخبات المصنفات دوليا ونجح في الفعل كان
يتصدر المجموعه السادسه بعد تغلبه على
كرواتيا وصعد بالفعل الى دور 16 لاول مره
في تاريخي المغرب منذ 36 عاما الا انه
يغير الارقام الان ويصل الى دور الثمانيه
ليحرز هذا الانجاز التاريخ الكبير ليس
للمغرب وحدها ولكن ايضا للعرب والافارقه
ممثلا لهم في بطوله كاس العالم هو سيلتقي
بالفائز من مباراه البرتغال وسويسرا وهي
مباراه حسنه ايضا يمكن النظر اليها لتعرف
على واحسن واصل مع حضراتكم برص الاحتفالات
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه مع زميلي ليله
بازاري مره اخرى وهو واقف الان وسط
احتفالات واسعه للجماهير المغربيه
والعربيه
رشا كان نوصل على سوق واقف ولكن للاسف
الجماهير هنا كثير
لا استطيع اتجاه هناك زحمه السير
والانطلاق الى السوق واقف ولكن قبل قليل
كانت اغاني مغربيه سميره سعيد ونيوريوم
كانت اغاني مغربيه اخرى شباب من الوطن
العربي ليس فقط من المغرب
[موسيقى]
تكون البطوله المغربيه
كلها همم فلسطين ومن تونس الجزائر
المنتخب المغربي الحمد لله وكانت المقابله
مع اسبانيا كان شويه قويه والحمد لله قدر
على المقابله ونوديهم الى همم ركلات
الترجيح الحمد لله ما شاء الله عندنا
الحارس
همم ضربه الجزاء
ان شاء الله
جول
على كل حال اذا اخذنا الكاميرا بالمنطقه
الثانيه رشا وسنشهد الحشود التي تتجه نحو
المترو الذي همم طبعا همم الذي سينتجه نحو
همم سوق واقف حيث الاحتفالات هناك سيكون
الاحتفال الاكبر هذه مازلنا في منطقه ملعب
المدينه التعليميه التي ستنطلق منها
الحشود الى سوق واقف الى اللؤلؤه الى
قطاره الى مناطق مختلفه من العاصمه
القطريه الدوحه وهناك ستكون الاحتفالات
كبيره الجميع سوف يعني همم تكون شاهدنا
كيف عندما فاز المغرب قبل هذه المره
السفاره من المغرب بدي اسالكم سؤال
فرحتكم اليوم
كبيره بزاف بزاف بزاف ان شاء الله احنا
اكيدين غانكونوا في الفاينال وراح نشرفوا
المغاربه والعرب راح يكون فوز عربي
الامه العربيه كلها ان شاء الله وانا اكيد
اه راح نشرفوا العرب
جوابها اكيد ههه
ديال الجمهور المغربي همم
مبروك علينا وعلى العرب كلهم
اه ههه مبروك علينا الفوز ان شاء الله راح
نضلوا الفاينال انا اكيده
مدام كاس العالم دوله عربيه كاس العالم
هياخذوا المغرب ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله
كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
عرب عرب مغرب مغرب مغرب باذن الله
شكرا شكرا لك ليس ابقى معي وليبقى معك
ايضا هذه الجماهير تبقى معنا
سنواصل لرصد هذه الاحتفالات المغربيه
والعربيه بعد هذا الفصل
[موسيقى]
ونعود مره اخرى الى رصد الاحتفالات
العربيه والمغربيه بعد نجاح المغرب بالفعل
في تحقيق هذا الانجاز التاريخي والتاهل
لاول مره لدور ثمانيه بالمونديال كاول
فريق العربيه ينجح في تاريخ هذه البطوله
بطوله كاس العالم في الوصول الى دور
الثمانيه كانت مفاجاه كبيره لكل العرب
وكانت فرحه عامه بعد ان نجح حارس المرمى
ياسين بونو في التصدي لكل الاهداف
الاسبانيه ولم تنجح اسبانيا في تحقيق ولا
هدف واحد من ضربات الجزاء الترجيحيه التي
كانت العنوان الرئيسي لختام هذه المواجهه
الساخنه ما بين اسبانيا والمغرب والان
نعود مره اخرى الى زميله ليس من قلب
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه ومعه المغربيات
الاشقاء والمغاربه ايضا الذين يحتفلون في
هذه اللحظات وهي فرحه مشتركه لنا جميعا
الهتافاتنا
المغرب كيخلع شرب سماء المغرب
[موسيقى]
المباراه
احنا بالمغرب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ان شاء الله المغرب بيمثل كل العرب نتمنى
ان يعني نمثلوا العرب الكل احسن تمثيل
وتحيه للمنتخب المغربي وتحيه للجمهور
الكبير المغربي
[تصفيق]
اليوم هو يوم مشهود في تاريخ العرب وفي
تاريخ قطر شرفتنا قطر بهذا التنظيم وما
كناش عند الموعد كنا فعلا نحن المغاربه
نحن في اقصى دوله عربيه هي المغرب واقصى
دوله في الشرق هي قطر وكنت ان الفرصه
اليوم بيننا اقصى دوله في الشرق مع اقصى
دوله في الغرب اعطونا دخلونا التاريخ
وتاريخ مشهود تاريخ بالبطولات وكنت منه
هذه اليوم هو يكون بدايه لتاريخ اخر الله
يكبر بحس فيه دمع بعيونك
اليوم هاد اليوم ما يمكنش توصف وكان شكر
جميع جميع
العرب بالخصوص على يعني المجهودات
يعني الحضاره القطريه فين وصلت العرب
وكندا بان هذه بدايه
الحارس الطور الشعوب وشكرا لكم وشكرا
للعربيه شكرا شكرا هذا الاجواء طبعا في
عندنا برضه فتيات قتل اتينا قبل قليل
خرجوا من المغرب من الملعب قبل شوي
بتحكي لنا
مد
ربي كما قال المدرب ديالنا وكانشكرو بزاف
اللعابه داروا اكثر ما في جهدهم همم
وشكرا لجمهور اللعابه
[موسيقى]
125 دقيقه كامله شكرا وشكرا كل هديوهات
الفوز ديالنا
للجلالات الملك محمد السادس وشكرا بالزاف
القاع العرب اللي كانوا مساندينه الصراحه
همم
اهلا وسهلا
[تصفيق]
هذه هذه الانستغرام
السعودي حاضر
اليوم كانت كل العرب المغرب والمغرب كانت
كل العرب الف مبروك المغرب اختاروا الخيار
الاسعد عن طريق بوابه اسبانيا يرفع راس
العرب 1000 مليار مبروك
للنهائي ان شاء الله الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ان الاسود الاطلس ستكتب تاريخها في قطر
شكرا شكرا
الاجواء هنا طبعا
الاحتفالات المغربيه بامتياز الجميع هنا
يعني يقوم
بالغناء بالتصفيق بالفرح بالتعرف على
الاخر كثير من العرب تعرفوا على بعضهم
البعض خلال المباريات خلال
كل هذه المشاعر التي حملت الفرحه وسعاده
الكبيره بوصول المنتخب المغربي ممثلا
لشمال افريقيا اول العرب في هذه البطوله
بطوله كاس العالم لاول مره في تاريخ
البطوله يصل منتخب عربي الى دور ثمانيه
الف مبروك للاشقاء في المغرب تحيه كبيره
للمنتخب المغربي والتحيه ايضا لزميلي ليث
بازاري مفرد العربيه الذي نقل لنا فرحه
الجماهير العربيه والمغربيه من قلب
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه وكنا معكم على
مدار هذه الساعه ننقل لكم افراح واحتفالات
الجماهير العربيه في داخل المغرب وفي ايضا
الدوحه وفي باريس وفي عدد من العواصم
العربيه